التصيد الاخطاء في دراما رمضان هو مسلسل
بحد ذاته ففي كل موسم درامي رمضاني
بيبداوا المشاهدين من اول يوم يطلعوا
اخطاء سواء اخراجيه او دراميه او في
التصوير او حتى اخطاء تاريخيه خلينا
نستعرض مع بعض اكثر الاخطاء اللي الناس
متداولتها من اول رمضان والبدايه من مسلسل
الزند
العاصي اللي هو بطوله النجم تيم حسن
ومجموعه من النجوم الاخرين ومن اخراج سامر
البرقاوي الناس تداولت صوره لمشهد بيظهر
في اللوح طاقه شمسيه على سطح احد المنازل
مع انه احداث المسلسل بتدور في نهايه
القرن التاسع عشر في عهد الدوله العثمانيه
يعني اكيد ما كان في الواح طاقه شمسيه
وقتها اما المسلسل الثاني فهو مسلسل ستهم
من اخراج رؤوف عبد العزيز واللي بتقوم
ببطولته الفنانه روجينا واللي تداولوا
الناس صوره لها بتبين فيها ابتسامه هوليود
واللي هي اجراء تجميلي معروف في الاسنان
بيزبط الاسنان او بيزبط شكلها والناس
استغربت الموضوع كونروجينا بتادي دور سيده
فقيره في الصعيد ويعني مو لايقه على هذا
الدور وهذا التعليق تحديدا ما جابت
لروجينا بس لانه شفنا كثير تعليقات على
اسنان فنانين وفنانات اعتبروا الناس انها
مو لايقه على الادوار اللي بيقدموها هذه
غير التعليقات الدائمه على الفيلر
والبوتوكس وغيرها
مسلسل سر الباتع اخراج خالد يوسف واللي
كان ضيفنا في اول الحلقه كان له نصيبه من
الاخطاء والانتقادات وتناولناها في بدايه
الحلقه ورد عليها المخرج تكلمنا عن لباس
الجنود الفرنسيين
وملامحهم وطول قامت الفنان اللي بيؤدي
شخصيه نابليون واللي معروف عنه انه قصر
القامه المخرج كريم الشناوي هو كمان لقت
لنفسه خطا في عنوان احدى حلقات مسلسل
الهرشه السابعه وتداركوا واعتذر عنه كمان
وهو خطا في كتابه عنوان الحلقه مثل ما
شايفين كيف مكتوبه كلمه استحمى وكان
المخرج مثل ما قلت تزارك الخطا واعتذر عنه
تفسير ومو تبرير الخطا ومن اخطاء
المسلسلات المرصوده كمان خطا اتكلمنا عنه
في حلقه امس وهو من مسلسل رساله الامام
اللي بيروي حكايه اخر سنوات من حياه
الامام الشافعي فشفنا الشاعر سوري طلع
واتهم صناعه المسلسل بسرقه ابيات شعر هو
كاتبها وتم نسبها للشافعي وذكرى في
المسلسل على لسانه على انها من تاليف
الامام هذا الخطا الكلام بالعاميه مع اكثر
من تعليق اخر كانوا صناع المسلسل حاولوا
يتعاملوا معاهم كلهم واضافوا تنويه في تتر
المسلسل انه هذا مو مسلسل تاريخي بل
معالجه دراميه لكن اليوم على فكره شفنا
تطورات في القصه فالشاعر صعد اكثر واعلى
المقادات صناع المسلسل وبدء اتخاذ
الاجراءات القانونيه ضدهم وعلى فكره
المراجع والمدقق اللغوي للعمل كان طلع في
بوست على فيسبوك وهو رئيس مركز اللغه
والثقافه العربيه في جامعه القاهره دكتور
احمد عمار قال في بوست على فيسبوك سمى عن
فضيحه الامام قال لو ثبت انه الابيات مول
الشافعي فهذا خطا لا يغتفر ولا يمكن
الدفاع عنه باي شكل من الاشكال وقال انه
ما كانت شغلته المراجعه التاريخيه وهو بس
كان بيدقق لغه وقال انه مو شغله المدقق
اللغوي البحث في مرجع النص لكن في هذه
الحاله كان عليه الانتباه الى الكسره
العروضي في الشطر الاول ويبحث عن اصل
البيتين لكن لم ينتبه لهذا مع انشغاله
بضبط النص واعتذر عن هذا الخطا الكبير مثل
ما سماه رغم انه مو المسؤول عنه على الاقل